Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
September 18 2017 what's going on?
How are Ya?
How's it going everybody? How are you
starting a new way? Get them out there.
Put your pants on one leg and a
thigh. Joe. Six pack. Going to work.
Um, I got to keep it down. This isn't new.
This, this is the new, uh, more subdued,
quieter podcasts.
Now that I have a baby daughter,
um,
I'm recording this Sunday night and uh,
that's all you need to fucking know my
fucking are you hearing that or you're in
some sort of weird noise there.
I don't know what I did.
My fucking mixer is acting weird. What
happens if I pushed his button? Anything?
Anything. Oh, there you go.
Just goes into one speaker and then
the other one had fallen in the other.
How are you, did you enjoy your football
Sunday? Did you Julia sports weekend?
Did you follow politics?
Did you watch college football?
You just stare at the wall. Drinking
booze, ignoring your loved ones will,
if you did,
I'm jealous.
Billy. No booze. Billy. What Ha. Oh,
tell me where'd your booze
go? Bill Lee. Boy. Billy boy,
tell me where did you booze go?
Charming Billy.
It's sitting over there and every
night a fuck can steer a bird.
I can't have a fucking drop
cause I got active work.
Yes I can have a fucking
job cause I got acting work.
See I'm slowly losing my mind.
Yeah.
What if I just said one
bill, Lee boy, POB boy.
What if you just had one charming Billy?
Well then I drink the whole bottle and
I've taught computer on the couch and I'd
be a fat fuck on camera.
Hd.
I'm down to one 76 and change,
I mean been working out because I was
playing catch and fucked up my fucking
calf. That's how old I am. So I've
just been eating like an angel.
Okay.
You know,
after every bite I count and I chew
fucking 27 times on each side of my mouth.
And then I take the Napkin and
I wipe off like a fucking angel.
If there is a god,
La,
whatever the fucking peanut butter
sandwiches you're read to. And with that,
our law peanut butter sandwiches.
I wonder if fucking the couch getting
any death threats from extreme Muslims.
Well, maybe he was Muslim. I don't know.
They never really said God knows
sesame street was liberal enough.
They probably would have thrown
that in back then. Right.
And then Bob would be fucking
singing that song. Uh, what is it?
Who are the people in your neighborhood?
Neighborhood. A neighborhood. Oh, who
are the people in your neighborhood?
The people that you meet each day.
Oh,
fucking puppet vampire.
That happens.
Be Muslim is in your neighborhood
was too long. That's what it was.
It was too fucking long.
Um,
you haven't had Devon had a drop
of booze in fucking 32 days.
32 fucking God damn days. I'll die right
now. I'm not even gonna lie to you.
This was the longest month and a
day of the year without a doubt.
Um, it's fun in the morning.
It's not in the evening.
Like right now. I just want to
get fucking blasted, you know,
I dunno. Can't do it. They'll
can't do it. Gradually coming down.
I got to get down to a buck
72 my fighting weight is Bob.
Pogo says onF is for family
season two while you're watching,
are you liking how you're
giving it a thumbs up,
whatever the fucking scoring system
is over there at Netflix. You know,
I don't know what they use it now and I
think they said they're going to go with
thumbs up, thumbs down. And I think
they stuck with the star system.
I have no idea. I don't
pretend to know. Um,
my whole fucking weekend it's just been
about keeping my fucking leg raised.
I went to this fucking party on Thursday
night with my lovely wife and the
fucking host of it was given a big speech
and I was stone sober and I had to go
over and sit in the corner was outside
in this guy's lawn with like a tent.
Right.
And I'm sitting,
I go off in the corner to sit
down stone sober with a fucking,
I had like club soda and lime.
The hardest thing for me to order, cause
I can never remember what you're saying.
I can just for some reason I can never
remember club soda cause I never ordered
and half the time I go up to the
bartender at the Va, what can I get you?
I'm like,
yeah,
what's that thing people drink when they
don't drink and then they go club soda.
I go yes with alive.
And then if you're trying to be
funny like a third of the time,
that's how I have to order it because I
can't remember what it is cause I never
ordered.
So I'm on my second club soda and lime
in this guy who's hosting the party.
Fabulous hose.
He's fucking tank and all these people.
I had to go outside the tent because I
see a stone wall where I could sit down
because my fucking ankle
is filling up with fluid.
Um, and it's becoming twice the size, my
other ankle. But you know, I went to the,
you know, I just went into some walk
in clinic and the guy looked at it. Oh,
I'll tell you what. I'll tell you. I
can tell you what you did right now.
I can tell you for a cross the fucking
room without even doing an x ray,
you know, walk in clinic
type Shit, you know.
So I go to sit down the guys in
the middle of this great speech,
everybody's fucking listening
and I don't know how,
but I set my glass down and I
reached back to get something.
I knocked it off and it made that
and it was like a fucking wine glass.
So it sounded like a booze glass in the
middle of his speech and like half the
10 fucking looks over me. I spilled it on
my link. I did all of this stone sober.
So my [inaudible] comes walking out. She's
laughing at me going, what did you do?
And I was all embarrassed going,
I was going near stomach and a scene.
I felt bad enough as it was. And then she
got mad at me cause I got like, I got,
you know,
I
got emotional with her so she didn't,
didn't talk to me for like two
fucking days because of that.
But two fucking day she started
talking to me. You know what I mean?
Like if she ever spilled a drink on
herself and half a tent to people looked
over at her and I walked over and said
like, what did you do? Like, you know,
mad she'd be at me. But that's how
it works in the male female dynamic.
All right?
You're either wrong or you were
too mean when you were right.
That's basically how it was.
That's what it was.
I think I was guilty of being
too mean. So anyways, I, um,
I watched a little bit of the Patriots
today. I saw the first quarter,
I taped the game. I'm going
to watch the rest of it, uh,
patriots with a little bit better today.
Obviously it's early in the season,
you know,
this is what they always do.
They hype up shit because people are went
beating teams are losing to teams and
all this shit that you're not going to
see in January. Who gives a fuck, right?
That's just getting going.
And um,
I actually went to a,
I went to the stub hub center today
and I saw the new Los Angeles chargers,
their first game against
the Miami Dolphins. Um,
I went down there, I got to tell
you, that might be the best stadium.
I've seen a football game
and at the NFL level,
simply because there was
only 25,000 people there.
I can't believe the patriots are
playing the charges on the road.
If I could see Tom Brady and
a 25,000 seat stadium of,
it'd be fucking incredible.
That's like the old, that's what,
what the old NFL used to look
like back before. You know,
we out fucked all of those other stadiums
back before lady Gaga and fuck it,
Whitney Houston, everybody brought
all these other people into the game.
All these people who are just like,
oh my God,
what else happens after the concert?
You know,
when they started watching football,
so they had to build 50, 60, 70, 80,
a hundred thousand fucking seat stadiums,
25,000 seat seats.
I got to see two wily veterans
to gunslingers, Philip Rivers,
Philip Rivers against a,
what's his face? Said?
Jay Cutler's at Jay or Jake? Jay
Cutler. That's right. Jay Cutler, right?
Am I going to say his name
right? Jay Cutler. I like it.
One guy's a fucking religious frequent
90 kids. The other guys like set them up,
set them up. Let's have another drink,
right? Jay Cutler. There you go.
That's right. Jay Cutler. So I'm fucking,
San Diego had the Goddamn game one.
Wait, this is showing me a
body builder. Is it Jake?
Okay.
This is the age I'm at now. I don't
know anybody's fucking name anymore.
Jay Cutler.
There we go.
No, it is Jay Cutler. All right. Whatever
the fuck this fucking guy, right?
He key key leads his
team down the field day.
Go ahead by three points and then San
Diego comes down the field. Philip Rivers,
he doesn't give a shit
either. He's worried about a
fucking two minute offense.
This guy's got nine miles to feed.
You bet you have a nine kids.
Just it's, you just come
home to a standing ovation.
Everybody's freaking as here.
You have a crowd, you have a
fucking crowd of kids. Oh, amazing.
Is that till they all become teenagers
and then there's a 10 to 15 year period
where they hated you. You know,
you never made sure that I know.
So God staked down. You always sat
down the other end of the table.
I wanted to sit closer to you and then
he's going to deal with all of that shit.
Right. Um, was a great game.
Fantastic fucking stadium.
MMM,
dead great.
There's not a bad seat in the house.
I'm telling you before they moved to some
giant monstrosity of a fucking stadium
that this Sharon with the rams, I believe.
And it's going to fucking, you know,
bankrupt his city.
Um hmm.
Before they fucking do that.
Eat. If you get a chance,
definitely go to the stub hub center.
It's fucking phenomenal. You know,
it's funny, I was, I was sitting,
I was watching the game and I see this
guy flying over in this helicopter,
the Robinson 44 during a fucking game.
He's,
he looks like he's not even 500 feet off
the fucking gruff flies right over the
fucking stadium. And I, with my
limited knowledge of aviation,
realize that when there's
a big event like that,
it's an automatic temporary no fly zone.
An hour before and an hour and after
the game, I believe that what is,
if not two hours before and after,
right?
This fucking jerk off flies
right over the fucking stadium.
And I'm sitting there with my buddy going,
ah, that didn't look like a cop. Right?
You can't, I don't think you can
fucking do that. I'm just a novice,
but I do not think you could do that.
This fucking jerk off comes by again.
He's on his side showing all
the passengers down in it,
and then like two seconds late, like
a police helicopter comes flying over.
I don't know if he got in trouble
or what, but, uh, I dunno.
I know some pilots listen to
this shit. I, like I said,
I don't ever pretend to know anything
about that stuff as far as, uh,
my limited knowledge.
You are not allowed to do that.
God forbid something happens and then you
fucking land on 25,000 people watching
fucking Jay Cutler,
right?
With keg booze coming out of
his pores going up against, uh,
the other guy from Ash
Wednesday, right? Um, uh,
these Kansas city chiefs
for real. Uh, so I,
I fucking got a taxi on the way down.
MMM.
And then on the way back,
I called the car service and I'm
fucking tell him this guy, I'm like,
meet me at one 84 and Avalon.
All right,
there's a Kentucky Fried Chicken
right next to a doughnut place.
Can you fucking meet me there? Right.
So the guy is like, yeah, I was good.
All right, great. Great. All right, so
we get down there, right? The game ends.
I walk out there for 15.
He's supposed to pick me up at four 30.
I called the guy up, he's like a fucking
city block away. Everything's going good.
Then all of a sudden the cops are
everything and they're like, dad,
like Uber and Lyft. One 92, I walked down,
walked down to one 92. Right? And
I'm sitting there going, well,
I'm not Uber or Lyft car
service. I'm like, these guys
are going to fuck with me.
So I try and call this guy. I called the
guy up and I keep telling him, the guy,
he's gone to grab a block away. I'm a
block away and I'm going, yes. Yeah,
I forget the Kentucky, the KFC
and go, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't KFC now. No, KFC. There's
a doughnut shop right next door.
I'm going to walk over, see
if you can turn it in there
and he goes up, go up. See,
I'm going, no, no. Listen. I'm
walking over, walking over. All right,
forget it.
You can't walk into the doughnut place.
I'm going to go down to one 92 in Avalon.
He goes, okay, give me a parking lot,
KFC.
He just kept saying that like a prank
show and I'm literally getting angry.
Okay.
Yelling,
no.
One 92 an Avalon into my phone and like
people with kids and turn around looking
at me. So I'm trying to put more of a
happier tone in my voice and it's just not
working and he just kept going,
okay, KFC parking lot. I come, no,
one 92 when the Avalon, and then I
finally got to just repeat it, repeat it,
and he goes, yes, yes, I will
repeat what I said. He goes,
one 92 Avalon. I go, fine,
fine. And then like he's calls me back,
hook up, pulling into the donut shop.
I finally had to fucking take a picture
of one 92 in Avalon and send it to the
fucking gun. Ain't showed up. Right.
And he was the greatest guy ever.
Greatest guy ever. And I was
like, all right. You know what?
Maybe I got a little emotional.
Okay,
there's 25,000 people walking up
and down the Goddamn street here.
I don't know what to do here.
Maybe, you know, I don't know what,
but I will tell you that
when I was at the game,
okay.
Um, go. See when I was
at the game, the, uh,
these people in front of me, I've never
seen this before. We're drinking. Uh,
what's that Mexican
beer that begins with a,
with an m begins with an M bay.
It's in a,
it's fucking gold,
right?
It looks like there's almost
like a trophy looks delicious,
especially after 32 days in that booze.
And so these people in front of me are
drinking this shit in it, out of a can.
And they had this shit, this shit on
top. I'm like, what the fuck is that?
Is it crushed red pepper flakes?
What is,
and this guy next to me goes chili powder.
They put chili powder around the
topic cause I don't like it. I'm like,
is that like white people putting a lime
and a fucking corona? He goes, yeah,
it's something like that. He
goes, you know, I don't really
like it. And I was like,
well, I got to try that.
I mean, not right now,
but eventually I'm going to try that.
Um,
it looked like the shit that you put
on the warning track. So these new, uh,
baseball stadiums,
it's sort of sanded sort of rubber.
That's what it looked like
for fucking far away. Um,
so that guy proceeds to get absolutely
plastered and after three fucking,
um,
quarters,
he comes back up and yells to the crowd
that they stopped serving beer at the
start of the fourth quarter and he's
yelling about how dumb it is. And, uh,
that's one of those moments where it was
good that I also wasn't drunk cause I
would have been like, yeah, buddy,
you're the reason you're the fucking
reason they do that because you can't hold
your alcohol. Look at you,
you're a fucking mess.
So I actually went to this game
and this is like a record for me.
I didn't have any booze and I
didn't eat any of the shit food.
I had like two handfuls of fucking
peanuts and drank like three waters.
That's it. Because I can't be a fat
fuck on this thing, you know. So, um,
okay,
I fucking go downstairs and take a piss.
Right.
Okay.
And he's this fucking guy just yelling
at the police and there's like two cops
there and then there's three and then
there's five. And I'm walking by.
I go down and take a piss and I come
back and there is like half the police
force is standing there and is this
white dude screaming at all of these cops
screaming, you got to do some, go
up there and, and do something.
Another white guys yelling, dude,
it was like total white guy moment.
You're like yelling at fucking 20 cops.
He's not getting the shit kicked out of
him. And they actually listened to it,
went up,
they'd kick two guys out and the other
guys were like really fucking like, oh,
all right. They just sort of
left. I don't know what they did.
I Dunno what the fuck they did.
It was the weirdest thing
was the two guys screaming,
looking like the ones that we're
going to get fucking arrested. Um,
but we're demanding that these cops go
up and do something and then they finally
fucking did when they throw these guys
up. It's a really bizarre day, but I'm,
but once again,
a phenomenal fucking a sports
experience if you go there. So, um,
I apologize. A lot of this shit
is going to be all sports stuff.
That's kind of what I did this weekend.
I can't hang out with my daughter and I
just watched a bunch of sports and uh,
did anybody put on the NFL network
and watch Dan Marino a football life.
Okay.
It was fucking amazing.
But like you can't do the Dan
Marino story in fucking 30 minutes.
That should have been an hour
and a half long it least.
And as much as he five feel
like the finally got his
fucking do is you watch and
Troy Aikman, Peyton Manning, Brett Farve,
all of them saying this was the guy,
this was the fucking guy.
Then finally putting to bed this
whole thing that you know that,
because he didn't want a Superbowl,
like that's some sort of like,
okay,
black mark up against the
guy's fucking name, the guy,
he was so ahead of his time, he was such
an unbelievable fucking quarterback.
It took 25 years,
a quarter of a century,
and a massive change in
the rules of passing in.
How you could defend against the past for
people to start fucking with what this
guy did from 1983 on.
Um,
he was unbelievable.
You know what kills me is his
dad taught him how to throw ball,
come the arm comes up,
ball comes out.
And I can't even tell you how
many times as a patriots fan,
we played them twice a fucking year.
I thought Andre tip had had him,
he's armed with the football would still
be at his waist and Andrea was bringing
his fucking arm down to get them
in somehow as armored come up.
And it'd be out 40 yard fucking laser.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
He used to kill us.
He used to kill for all you young dolphin
fans out there. That fucking Tom Brady.
You know,
cause he's been beating your ass two
games a year for like almost his whole
career. Just about, um,
that's payback for Dan Marino.
I'm telling you,
Dan Marino today in his prime would
easily throw for over 6,000 yards easily.
And if you could actually win
without having a running game,
which you can nowadays,
the way that fucking game has changed,
he would have at least one Superbowl
ring. Okay. I'm telling you, um,
if one of my favorites of fucking all
time and I'm glad they finally did, uh,
the football life and I think it was
at least an hour too short. All right,
day you go. I've said my piece that's
coming from a patriots fan too.
And when he played, I fucking
hated him because he, he killed us.
I didn't really hate them, but you know
what I mean? I wasn't pleased with him.
All right, let me do the
little bit of the, uh,
some has to break up this sports stock
guys. I gotta I gotta do the fucking,
I got to do the reeds here. All right,
everybody, it's Helix Hallux. Uh,
you know something.
There were a ton of online mattress
retailers popping up these days.
All with a one size fits all solution
to a better sleep. You know what?
I had no idea.
I do not have my ear to the ground
and the fucking mattress retail.
I didn't realize there was a whole bunch
of these people popping up. Oh my God.
If there's another online
merge was retailer, guess what?
One size doesn't fit all.
All right? He likes sleep.
Offers something that
doesn't exist anywhere else.
A mattress personalized to your unique
preferences and a and sleeping style that
won't set you back. Thousands
of dollars, dollars.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar take
their simple two to three minutes sleep
quiz.
They'll build a custom mattress.
That will be the best thing
that you've ever slept on. Um,
nonliving I should say, uh, for couples,
Dave even personalized
each side of the mattress,
the beginning of the
end of the relationship.
Everyone from Gq to cosmopolitan to the
New York Times are all talking about
helic sleep.
And once you try it out,
you'll know why your custom mattress
arrives direct to your door in a week in
shipping is completely free. Try It for
100 nights gross. If you don't love it,
they'll pick it up,
gross and refund you in full Jesus Christ.
So they take it to a sperm
donor place and wring it out.
It's how they make their money back in
the fucking shipping. Uh, all right,
go to go to helix,
sleep.com/bar right now.
And you get $50 towards
your custom mattress.
That's Heloc sleep.com/burr
for $50 off your order. Ha.
He likes sleep.com/ [inaudible] all right.
What are we going to to fucking
three more? Oh, look who's here. Oh,
[inaudible] me undies, Mia. Andy's
yelling at a bunch of cops. Doo, Doo, Doo,
Doo beyond ease me undies.
They won't arrest me even though
I'm a wop. Bottom wide enough.
They don't give a shit. That's all. And
everybody else out because I am white.
Share my balls.
Feel good in my privilege underwear.
Don't forget about the taint.
Sorry. And I apologized to him.
All Italian Americans offended
by that with the without papers.
Do you know what I learned?
A Irish wop I'd never heard of,
which was Nina.
So Italians that was
without papers and India.
India in fucking Irish.
Nina was no Irish need apply.
I didn't know that.
I had no fucking idea.
This is back in like
the gangs in New York,
and if you're actually offended by that,
you better be 100% Italian. All right?
Okay. Don't come at me with the
15% being 100% offended. Okay.
Um, I'll send you some fucking
pro flowers. All right? Me undies,
me undies will be the most comfortable
underwear pair of underwear you will ever
own.
Made from a sustainably sourced naturally
soft fabric that's three times softer
than cotton.
What they do is they punch a horse in
the head and they cut off its muscle and
then they put it right down here
where your junk is, you know,
and then the horse wakes up permanently
smiling for the rest of its life.
That's where the, you know,
that's where it comes from.
A lot of people don't know that.
That's what modelle is.
What else could be softer than
cotton other than a horses muscle?
I'm sorry for that image.
Okay.
Ultimate feel good undies for
when you want to feel naked.
Not and not be naked for the fellows.
Me undies, diamonds seen pouch,
lack a rhinestone all bag.
And once we got to the
words there. Um, this pouch,
the Freddie Mercury themed pouch
cradles your jewels and gives you a okay
mustache and leather hat not included
and gives you stuff to support it needs
without feeling too tight right now.
The one bites the dust.
Um,
ladies,
you will love the soft equal friendly
fabric pool to thought your pussy could
actually help the environment.
So soft and touchable 100%
satisfaction guaranteed.
They guaranteed you will love your undies
or your money back right now me and
he's has an exclusive offer
for just my listeners.
Get 20% off your first pair and free
shipping and me undies is so sure you will
love their underwear. They even
offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
You order a pair and if you don't love
your first pair, get a full refund.
This is a no brainer to try 20% off free
shipping, 100% satisfaction guarantee.
What in God's name are you waiting for
it to get your 20% off free shipping and
their 100% satisfaction
guarantee and get the best,
softest underwear you will ever own.
Go to me on [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com
slash bird this is a limited time offer.
So what are you waiting for? Start
wearing the best underwear of your life.
It changed my life according to the copy.
It's time to let me undies change yours.
Go to [inaudible] dot
com slash burr right now.
He is a new category.
I wanted to start and I should
really fucking know this guy's name.
I want to start a new thing to write in.
Okay.
So this podcast doesn't get any
more stale than it already is. Um,
is your favorite performances by non stars
and movies where you and your friends
still quoted?
It's an unknown fucking actor and
you may never even saw him again.
Never even seen the person again.
I'm so me. I'm going to kick it off.
I don't even know this actress named,
let me look this up.
He was in residences or why our dogs,
cop buddy, actor.
Let's see if I can find
the name of this guy. Um,
I don't know what this fucking guy's
name is. I got to give them a shout out.
You know, I'm going to hit pause because
I want to give this guy a shout out.
Okay. Unknown unheralded.
Unheralded actor.
Okay.
Um, as far as I know, rich
Turner in reservoir dogs.
Yeah.
It's one of my favorite fucking
just one scene actors. I've,
I've, I don't know, I don't watch a ton
of movies, but I fucking love this guy.
He plays the cop in the bathroom when a,
what's his face?
Tim Roth is sitting there with all the
drugs and he comes out and this is a dog,
a dog sniff and a the drug sniffing
dogs sniffing drug sniffing dog.
Um,
okay.
See was in pulp fiction too?
Meaning also.
Yeah. He wasn't in a lot of movies,
but he plays Mike. The way he,
he's being the cop and he's
telling that story. Just the way he
like the line. I said, buddy,
I'm going to shoot you in the face if
you don't put your fucking hands on that
dashboard. That's just the
way it's written in the way
he did it. He goes, I said,
buddy,
I am going to shoot you in the face if
you don't put your fucking hands in that
dashboard.
Just the way he said it.
I don't know why that sounds
exactly like a fucking cop to me.
So that was like something
just me and my friends,
we would be fucking hammered striking
out with chicks and you'd just be walking
out to your car and one of your
invariably would just go, buddy,
I am going to shoot you in the face.
And everyone just started laughing.
You don't put your fucking hands in
that dashboard. Who are your favorites?
Okay.
Who were your favorites?
They just had that one thing.
Your fucking friends you still quoted man.
Ice knew a bunch of those
is obviously a zillion guys.
Is it a zillion lines and
fucking Paul, uh, am sorry.
And I'm good fellas by the
way. Uh, rest in peace.
Frank Vincent,
the first big guy to go from
Goodfellas, man. I mean, what,
what an absolute legend.
What an absolute legend.
He was as amazing as an actor, as his hair
was. What a head of hair that guy had.
Good Lord Jesus Christ.
What a head of hair.
That guy had his whole frigging life.
That's what you say when you're bald.
You fucking see that on people.
Look at that guy.
I know if I ever had
that hair.
Some people, you know, some
people they just fucking,
I don't know what genes that guy is,
that guy,
he must add a Roman emperor or
something in his fucking family tree.
Um,
credible actor.
And so God damn funny, comedic
timing was incredible. Um,
I even love the commercially did
one I think is only line was oh,
when that guy was like stocking up the
freezer and he was disrespected him,
he and his buddy just
kept going. Oh, oh, um,
definitely going to miss him. And that
was definitely somebody on my bucket list.
You know, I get in a movie, I'm
like fucking two, three lines,
but that was definitely a bucket list
to ever be able to do a scene with him.
And what was so cool? Uh,
Michael Rappaport. Um,
quite possibly the funniest guy in
social media right now with this fucking
videos are so god damn funny.
Um,
he actually posted a picture on his
Twitter account. You should check it out.
I think it's,
I am at,
I am Rapaport and it's him working with
Frank Vincent in the early nineties.
Yeah,
it was like really early on.
And he got a picture of him shine and
Frank Vincent shoes and he said, uh,
at one time, Frank Vinson, uh,
maybe go home and get my shine box.
And what I love was a lot of people
now can look back on it, a classic,
and everybody's quoted it a zillion times,
but Rappaport already knew.
Go home and get your fucking shine box.
He was on that shit early.
Fucking early nineties. Uh,
they barely done editing it.
He already knew that that was
an instant fucking classic. Uh,
I got to get him back on the podcast
again. He has so many amazing stories. Um,
anyways, uh, let's skip that.
Let me finish this phone.
I had to break up the, the,
uh, podcast reading, I mean,
the advertising reading. Why?
Why don't we say the wrong thing first
before I correct it. I don't know bill,
cause you're dumb because you have a
zillion things on your mind. I know.
Fair enough. All right. Dollar
Shave club everybody. Um,
what you might not know,
there's a lot of things you do know,
but what you might not know,
I said Buddy,
is that dollar shave club also also has
products for pretty much everything else
you need in the bathroom.
Bodywash, Shampoo, hair, Gel,
don't need any of that. Lip Balm,
everything. What am I going to Moose,
my pubes uh,
at the store there are too many options
and you can't tell the difference
between any of them.
Then if you have any questions to clerk
usually doesn't know the difference or
it's still running the fucking
cash register. They can't
help you anyways. Right?
Well,
dollar shave club makes it
easy and convenient for you
to upgrade your shave and
your bathroom.
Do I have the hiccups?
All of a sudden now you don't have to
step foot in a store to get high quality
shave and grooming products.
This is right here. Why?
I would never invest in a fucking
strip mall. I swear to God,
I don't know what's going. I don't know
where these kids are going to meet.
You know, to get away from their fucking
parents when all the malls go away and
everybody's just getting their
shit delivered by drones. Uh,
now you don't have to step foot.
No fucking mar it dollar shave club
delivers them right to your door just like
their raises.
Everything is super high quality and we'll
leave you looking and feeling amazing
from premium ingredients
to sophisticated sense.
Dollar Shave Club's is changing the game.
If you're sick of the
nonsense at the store,
now's the time to try out dollar
shave club for a limited time.
Dollar Shave Club was basically
giving away their shit.
Shower Shave starfish set to
new members for only five bucks.
This start has said features
their executive razor and
three trial size versions
of their most popular products
that it you stay fresh and clean.
How much of the heterosexual women of
the world loving that they're doing this.
Ladies,
if you guys stinks just by him,
the shit shower shave packet for Christmas
and stuff in the stocking with a cute
little note that says take a hint
and you draw a little smiley face.
Um,
in your first box you will receive their
shave butter bodywash and one white
child Ali,
but wipes.
You will also receive their executive
razor, which includes their premium,
weighty, weighty handle and a
full cassette of cartridges.
After the first box replacement cartridge
cartridges are sent for only a few
bucks a month.
This offer is exclusively
available@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/per
dollar shave clubs, quality products.
We'll have you covered face to cheek,
to butt cheeks from face sheikhs to butt
cheeks. I fuck up that joke every week.
There's no better time to try the club.
And lastly,
but certainly not leastly the classic,
the Robert Deniro, the original,
the Pachino, the Marlon Brando,
stamps.com. Everybody stamp saving
time and they save you money,
which you can use to grow your business.
I can mail any letter.
Okay.
Package. I'm trying to be interesting
with my line read like that Guy Buddy.
I will shoot you any patch. I'm going
to read the next fucking sentence.
The way he broke that up.
Let me just finish this one first.
Any package using my computer and printer
and the mailman to pick it up or write
boring.
Yeah,
the hassle.
The post office.
Yeah.
In May. Let me think. For the
postcode I kissed. Oh, can't do it.
Doesn't have the rhythm and everything.
From postcards to envelopes to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes
online with no equipment to lease and no
long term commitment.
stamps.com we'll leave and help you
decide the best class of mail or your,
um, based on your needs. No need to
lease an expensive postage meter.
I use stamps.com whenever I send out my
posters because it been a whore myself
out at the end. No, I shows
for a couple of bucks.
Okay.
I'm a moron. If I can figure out,
so can you in right now? You too.
Can stamps.com servers with a special
offer that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale
without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
burb.
You are that stamps.com enter [inaudible].
All right. All right, well let's
get back to what the fuck. Okay.
Formula One. Did you think I was
going to talk about Formula One?
What'd you think I was gonna
talk about how Mississippi,
Mississippi State fucking
trounce my Lsu Tigers.
You know another one of my favorite teams,
Smu giving away 56 pounds per player
on the fucking offensive and defense
defensive line against Tcu.
C'Mon frogs.
How SMU was whipping that fucking Horn
toad ass for fucking the first half
before they wore him down.
He just leaned on him. Um,
do you think I was going to
congratulate the Cleveland Indians in an
unprecedented 22 in a row?
Does that what you thought I was going
to do you think I was going to do all of
that?
And I wasn't to talk about that Formula
One race down and fucking Singapore,
that race made me sick to one of
my favorite races of the year.
It's at night, it's in Singapore.
It's one of the most beautiful,
amazing slash kind of freaked me out
cities I've ever been to in my life slash
countries. Um, it really is
one of the most beautiful,
amazing fucking city where you
just feel like you're overbearing.
Parents are home all the time.
Um,
it was fucking rain. It was
night. It was raining out. Okay.
The Ferrari's were running great.
Daniel Ricardo was running great.
Mercedes wasn't doing that well,
you know,
I don't know if Hamilton at fucking,
I thought it was all tied up.
Maybe he was up by three points.
I can't remember.
But Ferrari needed to show up
on this fucking day. All right.
And if you watched when they were doing
the time trials on Saturday and you sell
what was like trying to drive
behind somebody doing 150, 60, 70,
80 fucking miles an hour with that
fucking rooster tail of water coming up.
I mean, it was going to be
an unbelievable fucking race.
God knows whoever's in fucking first
place and then first turn is going to win
the God damn race.
All right,
so Sebastian Vettel the Ferrari's,
they get first and third.
All right, well Daniel recard on the
red bull isn't second fucking place.
I believe that's the way it was.
Right?
Fucking Mercedes or back
and fourth and fifth.
So the Goddamn race starts
offer Ferrari has to do.
All he's gotta do is just make it to
the first turn in first fucking place
unscathed. He's going to win this
fucking race. Okay. Worst case scenario,
Hamilton gets fucking second place.
That's only 18 points.
Federal is going to get 25 he'll
pick up fucking, you know, whatever.
What does that seven points?
The fucking race starts.
Yeah,
Kimmy Reagan and he acted like
fucking Greg Brady. When, when?
When the pressure was on to beaten gotta
beat Marsha could to get close to the
quarter of an inch. He fucking
stomps on gas. Tries to go around.
Okay.
Oh, I'm sorry. It was Max Verstappen,
not Daniel car tries to go around the
guy that fucking tires get all fucking
yeah,
in a locked there when they
fucking go up and over.
Yeah,
he fucking fucks up his car.
Slams the fucking red bull
car into his fucking teammate.
Okay.
The other Ferrari Vettel
makes it to the first turn unscathed.
Meanwhile, fucking not on skate,
but he makes it there, but it takes,
car's fucked up. It got hit in the back.
Meanwhile, fucking lose fuck. And
Hamilton, he drives right around the shit.
Raise sneak sneaking by. Fuckhead
comes back in with this fucked up car.
Greg Brady,
right smashes in to the
fucking red bold guy again.
And who does he hit? He hits the fucking
Alfonso in the fucking orange car.
Try and do the exact same
thing as Lewis Hamilton,
but Lewis Hamilton's that Derek Jeter,
fucking star child,
just blessed 3000 hit the aid of
fucking grand. Slam one of these guys
in fucking Vettel drives like,
you know,
two more turns in the whole front of
his car. It comes off both Ferrari's,
out of the fucking race. They were in
first and third place, a first and fourth.
I can't,
I don't remember.
They had them.
They had them and they let off the hook.
They were both out of the race
before it even fucking started.
And all I could think is what
my dad used to always say.
When somebody would do something like
that, you'd be on crisis guy or that guy.
I said, okay, you could
fuck up a free lunch.
That's the first expression that popped
in my head. I think I tweeted it.
I was so fucking pissed. Ferrari
could fuck up a free lunch. I mean,
that was a free lunch. No one
could drive fast. That date.
Mercedes weren't running well the whole
fucking weekend. So what do you do?
You take out yourself and you fucking
teammate you clear out the whole fucking
front row.
So fucking Lewis Hamilton, who just
drives along unscathed. That guy,
Lewis Hamilton is a blessed man.
That's one of those deals.
He's one of those guys. Makes you
believe in a higher power like this.
Just somebody that just
fucking loves. I mean, I,
I'm taking away all the
preparation the man does, but
you know,
he cuts around the outside,
no problem.
Alfonso goes through the same thing
his fucking days over. Unbelievable.
And then the rest of the race and riding
around the fucking rain in Hamilton
fucking wins. No problem.
Unfucking believable.
Okay.
I wanted to see a race. I knew that
Hamilton was going to try to fucking,
he wasn't gonna be happy sitting in,
you know, all the way back there. Right.
Who would be right.
I wanted to see what the fuck he
was going to do with this car.
Not doing that well and all of that
rain. What? He actually crashed. I mean,
you know, he's going to push
it to the fucking limit.
All of that was out of the second.
It started like,
remember that year the jets was supposed
to be good and like fucking 99 and like
the first game,
Vinnie tested verde goes back and blows
out as Achilles and then Keyshawn was
crying after the game. That was the
original. That's my quarterback.
That was the original.
Um,
that's what it was like. I still watch
the fucking rice. It was still fucking,
it was still exciting by
Jesus Christ. Um, anyways.
Okay.
And then I also,
I watched the boxing.
That's all I did this weekend is I just
fucking watched a brain in an episode of
F is for family.
So I just stayed in the whole fucking
weekend when I wasn't writing.
I was just watching sports and,
uh,
I'm not a big boxing guy just because
I've gotten fucked over so many times in
the paper views. Uh, so
forgive me if I fuck up.
The pronunciation is a Golovkin first.
Conello and uh,
that took me back.
That's what pay per view.
Boxing. He used to be.
I'm not saying he didn't get fucked
every once in a while back then,
but it was just too, they was fucking
forehead to forehead. Just, it was a war,
feeling each other out, respecting each
other and all that shit. And then, uh,
the usual bullshit happened.
You know how that fucking lady saw at one
18 to one 10? I mean, I, I the Jesus, I,
I don't know shit about boxing.
And I was like, what the fuck? Um,
and I loved how Roy Jones in the
fucking end goes like, I, he goes,
I love that it was a draw,
you know,
cause that means we get to see this again
and next time there's definitely going
to be a decision. And I felt
that, I felt like he was like,
they were like, Roy, don't bring this up.
This is the Illuminati script of boxing.
Please don't bring this shit up. That
it's, this whole fucking thing is a,
that it was going to be a drive.
We had any way to make this thing be a
fucking draw so we could do it again.
Um, but it was great. It was a
great fucking fight. It's so,
I thought a glove can
clearly won the fight.
I just thought he was backing up the
whole fucking time. And uh, I know can,
I had some big shots towards the end,
but he glove could just fucking walk.
He ate them all up. He ate him up. He
just can, he would back off for a second.
You just come back and then he would
fucking give him, uh, you know,
if he took two, we'd come
back and give him too. I just
thought, you know, I dunno,
I agreed with you that,
that fucking guy who screams all the time.
No,
I got to fight the mood.
That guy, he's always screaming. Uh,
do they have them in the crowd
so we can't hear himself?
Does he not have headsets on? I loved
that he yells every fucking time. Um,
I dunno. I thoroughly enjoyed
it. The decision obviously stunk,
but I did not feel that
I got fucked on my money.
I feel like the fighter's got fucked and
I retweeted this rant that Teddy Atlas
went on and um, it was, you know,
somebody has to say, I just don't
understand how it's still that corrupt.
It's just, they've never
like, it was weird.
Like Vegas was totally
corrupt and totally mobbed up.
And then they cleaned it up by putting
those corporations in there who then
fucked you on everything,
including the steak.
Yeah.
Why can't they clean up boxing?
Can they get the mob out of this so that
the corporations can come over on the
legal side of stealing and fuck people
more than they ever have. Maybe they have,
I have no idea.
I don't understand it.
But a Teddy Atlas said,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna Butcher it.
How he said it.
He said those guys went in the ring
and came out less of who they were.
Meaning that they fit you do
permanent damage to yourself.
I mean,
will they will break it down the uh,
okay.
They will break it down, the power
shots and all of that type of shit.
And it's like I was watching
Rogan's recap of it.
Okay.
With Jim Norton and,
uh,
Rogan read some stats where this guy,
he took, okay. You know, here's the,
blew his head.
He took 118 punches to the fucking head.
I haven't taken 118 punches to
the head of my life. Am I bowled?
A brother used to beat the
shit out of me all the time,
but we knew you kept it to the body.
That's what your father wouldn't
see it when he came home. Um, so,
but other than that, I
mean it was, it was great.
It was everything that I knew that may
weather and m McGregor wasn't going to
be. And that's why I didn't rent it.
And that's why I spent my money on that.
I still got fucked.
MMM.
But, uh, it's Tommy
Morrison still alive. Okay.
I have to hit pause on this
cause I gotta watch this shit.
He's a relative of fucking
John Wayne in case she didn't know.
I'm sorry. He's a boxer back
in the day. Uh, all right.
I got to read some of the, uh,
the shit here for this week.
I can't see anything here doing
this in my fucking living room.
We bought these things
and where we, uh, yeah,
and another thing I had
to fix on this house,
say these fucking awful lights on
the wall. So we bought these sconces,
these really fancy fucking things.
And the thing,
the fancy thing in front of the
light is so goddamn thick that it,
it always seems like it's on a dimmer.
It probably should have just bought
a higher wattage bulb. I Dunno.
This has gotta be one of those
moments where you're like,
why the fuck am I listening to this guy?
He's talking about the fucking light
bulbs in his living room. I'm sorry.
All right. DNA testing
at Raven's game. No boy,
dear bill, I love the podcast.
Love you. Stand up. I Love
F is for family. Thank you.
I have to start promoting
that at my standup shows too
because I feel like a lot
of people still don't know the show's
on. Um, so if you get a chance,
if he give the show,
tell your friends about it and everything
just so we can continue doing the show
would be awesome.
He said,
I wanted to hear your opinion on
this very weird giveaway at Sundays.
Ravens game.
I'm a season ticket holder for the
ravens and it's not unusual to get little
freebies when you went to stadium
commemorative coins, beer, koozies flags,
et Cetera.
A Sunday is the home opener and some
company is giving away free DNA test.
So I guess this happened yesterday.
Free Dna test,
but he trying to do it. Figure out
if you're a fucking human being. Um,
and it's not even some ancestry.com
type shit that could give you some semi
useful information.
You're not getting any useful information
from ancestry.com they're doing what
this company is doing.
I don't know what they're doing,
but they're not trying to help you out.
Do you really need to know how much
Scottish blood you have in you that you
really need? What? So what you can do,
what go on and go feel justified by an
a fucking kilt. You're not Scottish.
You're a Mutt. Um, the
article I linked says,
uh,
they're testing for four genes.
The test offers insight into your mind,
body and health is what they claim.
It seems like this company just wants a
bunch of data and they figured that an
NFL game is a great way to get 70,000
mouth breathe and fucking morons.
Um, that, that part was me. 70,000
people, d 70,000 people's DNA all at once.
Uh, the company has also partnered
with the 40 niners. So testing my,
come to San Francisco soon.
What are your thoughts?
Keep up the good work
and go fuck yourself. Ah,
I think I know exactly what this is.
MMM.
In the future,
people's DNA is going to be a,
it's just starting to
become a revenue source.
The way your phone number and all of
this other shit that they get from you at
cvs and all these fucking places.
It was another revenue stream where
you were buying shaving cream tampons
whenever the fuck you doing and then
they would get personal information from
you that then they could then sell
to other fucking companies. Um,
I think it is now that
they've exhausted all of that,
they've now moving on to fingerprints,
face recognition in DNA and they're
going to share this with everybody.
And uh, I know the robots are
coming. I don't know how to,
I don't know where this all lands.
I know that there's talks in the future
that human beings could be meshed with
robots.
MMM.
If I had to guess,
they're probably going to get to the
point where with your DNA they can grow
another you and say,
well that's not really you.
The real you is going to the ravens game.
So we're going to do all
kinds of Nazi doctors,
Nazi doctor esque type experiments on
this with the fucking robot before we
release this to the public.
That's where I think it's going.
All right.
And you know,
I don't want my twin adult brother coming
into this world had 51 years of age
cause I figured another two years
we'll probably start doing it
and getting a fucking,
you know,
bionic arm put on as he's
screaming and fucking pink has,
God knows they're not going to use
fucking anesthetic cause that that fucking
DNA version,
you will be the property of a corporation
and we'll have no rights to fucking
mmm
anesthetic.
Why don't I write Scifi?
You know,
I did the whole fucking thing about how
you had to take a test and if you flunk
the test on the population control,
eh,
you just walk into the ocean and now
there's a movie coming out about that.
I Dunno,
maybe I'm just not original.
Maybe I should start writing these
fucking things and that sounds like a cool
fucking movie, right? Uh,
you have to go save yourself.
You know,
Hollywood do some fucking creepy happy
ending where you're just staring there
yourself touching each other's face
and everybody's fucking crying.
MMM.
I Dunno. You throw will Smith in there
somehow. It's a winner. All right.
Whiny fan complaining.
All right. Howdy bill.
I'm a four year podcast listener and I
saw you love and San Antonio early this
year.
I think your layers guy,
and obviously it should podcast
and I should go fuck myself,
but I think your Trump positions
are kind of unfair. Um, oh God.
Not another political fucking person.
He did call himself off of being,
I think your Trump positions
are kind of unfair.
Well then you think my Hillary ones
are fair. All right. God bless you.
I know you're just a comedian.
I know you have a lot of fans
in the quote real America. Ah,
there's the left talking
down to the right. Okay.
And so you have to tow align.
Isn't this? This is the classic, I really
hope the person wrote this is listening,
sir.
You're in,
you are inventing all of this in your
head because you're upset about something
politically. Okay? Are you mad at
what I'm talking about about Trump?
Is that what this is that you feel?
I have to tow some sort of fucking what?
Liberal Line because I'm
out here in Hollywood. Uh,
but Trump is, to my mind,
obviously a dangerous guy.
I won't go through my whole
list of grievance grievances,
but he thinks climate
change is a Chinese hoax,
a supports the white supremacists and
just this week through the lies of 800,000
I think that to make sure
he didn't use any comments,
you 8 million people who were brought
here as children into disarray.
I know every president has skeletons,
but even a liberal like me, Oh,
is a Hillary person can see this
guy is nothing like w w or George H.
Uh, dude, when did I say I liked this guy?
I never did.
I never said that I liked the guy.
I just said people freaking out about
them and losing their fucking shit.
I should've been more specific
like fucking white people
acting like the needle
in your life was going to change that
fucking far. All right. By the way,
um, you know, if you really
want to see a bunch of skeleton,
both of these people, I mean this
election was essentially 2:00 AM at a bar.
I mean, you had to go home with somebody,
right? Probably shouldn't have. Um,
listen, this fucking guy thinks climate
change is a hoax. Fine. All right.
Hillary was all for bailing out
these fucking banks in 2008,
which is exactly what the fuck happened.
And all these people who stayed in
Florida riding out the fucking storm and
everybody's making fun of them and saying
how dumb they are for staying there.
They're probably upside
down in their house.
And unlike the bankers don't have
another house that they can go to. Yeah.
Evacuate the area and do what?
Go with half of the Florida and sit
in a fucking waffle house in Georgia.
And then what?
I don't have enough gas money to get back.
I love the complete lack of sympathy
for people that can completely fucked in
which Hillary was totally all about.
She was also all about fucking
okay.
You know,
ignoring the wishes of the people on the
left who voted more for fucking Bernie
Sanders according to this
trial and colluded with the
Democratic Party to ignore
those votes in box.
Bernie Sanders out in and she just took
the nomination and now all of a sudden
she's got the fucking balls to sit here
and talk about the electorial college.
Okay. She's not a good person
either. And I'm not saying w was,
I told you I was done. I want
to say WME. Sorry. Donald Trump.
I said I was done with Donald Trump.
Okay.
When he said that both sides can
take contributed to the violence,
that he couldn't even get himself to say
that those Nazis might be a little out
of their fucking minds. The neonazis I
told you I was done with the guy. Okay,
but you hate the guy so much. You're
hearing what she want to hear. All right.
Maybe I don't Trump trashed
Trump enough on this podcast,
but I don't feel that I need to,
everybody,
at least in my profession has a bit
on how fucking stupid the guy is.
Million dry mouth talking about this shit.
So I don't, and for you to sit there,
you fucking cunt. After four
years of listening to my podcast,
acting like I tow some sort of line.
Did you,
do you ever listen to my fucking
advertise and I lose advertisers all the
fucking time. Okay. If I was
towing some sort of line,
I would read those things like
I was on fucking Lawrence Welk.
Hypen Geritol I don't.
Okay.
I tow a line as far as I say,
what the fuck? I think it's funny.
That's the line that I am
towing here, sir. I'm sorry,
the guy that you wanted to fucking win
didn't fucking win. I know. I know.
Trump's out of his fucking mind
and I don't need you wagon.
You fucking finger at me. Give me
a God damn fucking lecture. Yeah.
Okay.
Is if I don't understand that
this guy's fucked up. Okay,
so why don't you look at your,
I'll up your own fucking skirt.
Okay.
It'd be a little more even handed
all you fucking guys. I mean,
I guess you got to whine
about Trump because he's
actually the fucking president
of Jesus Christ.
The fucking,
I don't know what the fuck it is that
Hillary gets is, is unbelievable.
P S Hillary sucks. That's all
I get on this side. You know,
he said,
look man,
I just think that despite what
you're saying about being community,
you do have a platform.
Fuck you buddy. Fuck you.
You're not putting that on me. All right.
I can tell you this right now, dude.
If you get your political information
from a fucking standup comedian who can't
even read out loud,
you use this thing to decide who the
leader of the free world is going to be.
I can't help you. What am I supposed to
do? You know what I would say to you?
Send you fucking DNA into the ravens.
Um, anyways, you do
have a platform and why?
I'd never dare to tell you what to say.
I hope you will consider what happens
when you play down the danger of his
behaviors. Um, let me ask you this sir.
What exactly would be happening now if
the other fucking bought and paid for
fucking Twat went in there?
What do you think would happen?
What do you think would
happened? Huh? Do you honestly,
while she admits that global warming is
real, what do you think? What happened?
Do you think she's going to do anything
most the most she could be and therefore
is eight. Fuck, they just wait him out.
Al Gore in 1992 said that there has to
be a car that gets at least a hundred
miles a gallon by the fucking
year, 2000, something like that.
And it just kept delaying the project
and delaying it and delaying and delaying
it and delaying it.
And then they were out of office and they
just fucking went away. There you go.
So I don't know what to tell you.
I have to tell you buddy. Um,
I always vote outside of the
democratic and the Republican Party.
Okay.
Unless I find somebody within them,
like a Bernie Sanders
who I feel will actually,
hopefully make more people within those
bought and paid for fucking groups.
Uh, I don't know. Take a stand for
fucking regular people. I mean,
that's what I do. Okay. I
don't like Trump. The guy
makes me sick to my stomach.
I think he's a, I absolutely think
the guy's fucking racist. Uh,
but I also think Hillary is the
fucking devil in a lot of ways.
We sidestepped a bunch of other shit.
Okay.
We walked into a bunch
of the shit with Trump.
But you definitely sidestepped
the come on man. Everybody,
anybody with any remote sense of
intelligence knows that, you know,
that was the fucking Blue Bonnet bowl.
All right. That wasn't the fucking,
that wasn't Alabama versus fucking
Clemson or shit. That was uh, you know,
that was the holiday bowl election.
Alright. Actual money based, but I, I'm,
you know, I dunno. I Dunno why
you needed to send me that dude.
Do you honestly think that I want to
see fucking kids get sent out of this
country? I don't. I don't. Okay,
so stop turning me into the fucking,
you know what it is you want
of this country's fucked out.
There's a guy who can't read out loud
that does a podcast twice a week.
And I'm telling you that is,
if we could just get him to
politically say what we feel,
I think we could turn this country around.
Okay.
We're taking callers. I said, buddy,
um, actual money based on gold.
Hey,
Billy gold bullocks.
That'd be great. Have some gold bullets
in that fucking diamond encrusted pouch.
I was listening to Rogan's
podcast recently and he had
a guy called Peter Shift
on and he was talking
about gold money.com.
This is basically a private gold
reserve where you can buy gold,
which is held in a
secure vault. Oh, is it?
Listen, you give us our money and
we'll have, we'll hold your gold.
Great.
So they keep my cash and the goal,
do I got to send them a donkey toe
and using a prepaid mastercard,
you can pay for goods and services with
your money backed by gold or platinum if
you'd rather buy that.
Uh,
I would do that immediately or when the
dollar crash is effectively what the
banks used to do a before they sold the
foundations of our currency here is here
in the UK. Gordon Brown sold all
the diamonds that back sterling,
uh, when the bank shit the bed. Um,
I don't know what any of that
means. Here in UK. Gordon Brown,
who's Gordon Brown or is that a bank
like fucking JP Morgan,
uh,
sold all the diamonds that back sterling
when the bank shit the bed. Oh, okay.
So you got your money back.
Cause I was saying I just,
this minute signed up does sounds like
a commercial and I'll be putting some
money into it,
although not all my money as it's always
best to diversify when you stash of
saving.
I think it is much better than bitcoin
as it's actually based on something of
value. I love you to
go fuck yourself, sir.
Why don't you just take your
money and go buy a gold coin?
Why don't you just do that?
Why don't you take your paper and go
buy some gold and leave with the gold
rather than giving your money to this
fucking person you're not gonna meet any
tells you that he has got,
he know there's gold there.
He's basically doing what they're doing
with Fort Knox where they say there's
all this golden there and then there's
rumors that it's fucking empty. Um,
I liked the direction you're
going in, but uh, I think you, uh,
went out of the frying pan into
the fire with that one grant.
I don't want to shit on the whatever
that guy's doing because I got your
abridged version of it.
But um,
that reminded me of that movie blow where
Johnny Depp's character gives him $2
million in cash and they give him
a book that says $2 million on it.
Then he goes to jail. He never
gets his fucking money. All right.
My girlfriend's daughter
is causing us to break up.
Is that a bad thing? Um,
Jesus Christ. I mean,
you're already dating somebody
that already has a kid,
so that's going to be already a hundred
times harder to make that fucking work.
And then the kid doesn't even like you.
So I mean maybe she's
doing you a solid here.
MMM.
Hey Bill. Okay, here we go. So
my girl and I have seven years,
both work for the same company and I
was offered a better position in Florida
and she was also offered
a position as well.
Now here's where the daughter comes
in and fucks up the flow. Yeah.
Cause she fucking probably
wants to stay at her school.
Her daughter's 14 is just
starting high school,
just a foods refusing to move and her
mother is going along with not forcing her
to move and it's going to pass her
is going to pass on our position.
We agreed I will not move down and
get things in order until she wait.
We agreed I will move down and get things
in order until she gets there in four
years.
Now,
for the past few weeks we've been getting
into more fights in our reasoning for
the fight is sit down for this one bill.
She says it's easier for
me to leave when she's mad.
She's fighting you because it's easier
for you to leave when she's mad.
I think that's the dumbest fucking reason
I've ever heard. Also, she keeps saying,
I'm going to go down and find myself some
black ass and ended up cheating on her
while I'm there.
Okay.
We'd love to get your take on this
situation and get your insight on what I
should do. Thanks. And pick up a
fucking drink. You Pussy. Fuck.
Ah,
I would say A.
Okay.
I'd say there's a staggering
lack of trust. Um,
okay.
I think the key here is to not get into
an argument with her is to just sit down
and try and discuss it with
her and just say, listen, yeah,
mmm.
We agreed that this is what
I was going to do and now
what it is is I know,
I think this is what happened.
What she did was she did what was best
for her daughter and she put herself with
you in second,
but she still sounds like cares about
you and the fact that you're down there
and she's worried that you're
going to leave and she misses you.
I think that that's what's happening.
So I would just ask her,
it's just some like misdirected anger.
I,
we were actually just saying
that you miss me and you love me.
Is that what you're saying?
It,
we can work through this and then if
you're really not going to fuck around,
we're on her and you're really
going to see it through.
Then you want to be able to just say,
listen, I'll do whatever it takes.
I'm going to be there in four years.
If you're not lying,
I think you ought to be able
to work your way through it.
And I think this has less to do with
the daughter then it has to do with the
fact that she just misses you and
she's afraid that you're going to find
somebody else down there.
Evidently wherever you moved where,
uh,
there's a bunch of black ass down there.
That's what I was,
that's what I would guess.
So are you guys need to get on the
same page and you didn't have an honest
moment with yourself before you
fucking slowly tear the bandaid off.
Either get the fuck out of it are
totally commit to her. Um, I mean,
seven years at this point. Why didn't
you drop in a fucking ring on her?
Okay.
Done on a, shut her up for a
good couple of weekends. Um,
it won't shut her up permanently.
I can tell you that right now. Oh,
I can tell you some stories.
Oh,
can I tell you so, oh shit.
Right back in a or a tea latte.
11 mayor Reed Guy who jumps through all
the fucking hoops and still gets the
evil lot. All right. My wife,
uh, my wife is, uh, who were there,
Bill Billy Butler tits. Fuck you.
I'm losing weight. Uh, my wife,
my wife decided to have an
affair for months ago. Oh boy.
Before I knew what was going on,
she told me she didn't know if she wanted
to be married to me anymore and that
it was because I was too controlling.
And by controlling she means I
told her as a stay at home mom,
I had expectations.
I expected it to keep the house clean and
take care of our children as we agreed
when she quit her job.
Yeah.
Which is a totally fair ask,
you know. But nowadays in this
world of hyper fucking feminism,
not all feminists are bad,
but the fucking, the uh,
the god is great fucking
crazy ones there. Um, yeah,
they would say that that was
sexist. That, you know, well,
why don't you work all fucking day and
then come home and also have the house
clean. You know what I mean? Let me
look up. You got a bunch of kids,
it can only be so fucking clean, but
at least she could do is order a pizza.
Right? Um, anyways,
I would come home to her friends being
at the house and her drinking all
afternoon while Jesus Christ. She's
not even making an effort. Oh,
this is what happens when you draft
in the first round buddy. You know,
you get those second rounders, they,
they got some to fucking proof. You know,
that's just what happens when you marry
a 10. I'm assuming she's good looking.
If you putting up with this shit.
Uh,
I would get home from work after being
gone 15 hours and a half to say something
about how I felt that the house was a
wreck and there was no dinner and sight.
It never seemed to matter.
Back in January,
we moved to Denver from Atlanta
thinking everything would be better.
And she met this 25 year old guy who
she proceeded to sneak around behind my
back with and bring our children around.
No Way.
I'm 38, she's 35. We have two children and
we've been married for almost 12 years.
Yeah, Dude. Yeah. This is a wrap. Yeah,
and now she wants a divorce to plans
to move this kid into our home with our
children. Oh my God, Dude.
Okay.
This is the worst person ever.
I am beside myself with the thought of
the divorce and this punk living with my
children. Oh my God. I know it won't last,
but the fact is I don't want my children
to be around this piece of shit,
let alone living in my house.
She thinks this is,
she thinks this is perfectly okay
to put the kids and I through this.
I do love her and would do
anything to save our marriage,
but the truth is she's delusional
at this point and I guess I am too.
What do I do this?
Stop this.
I know this is not my fault because I
busted my ass to build the life she always
dreamed of. Only for her to
think she can kick me out of it.
Any advice and or the lovely nick you
could give would be greatly appreciated.
Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. Yeah,
man. I mean, this is the things,
this is what can happen to a guy.
MMM.
But you're not allowed to talk about
this on television are you? Never,
never, never. You can talk about guys
being overbearing, domestic violence,
all those things that
should be brought to light,
but they will not talk about this.
You Watch doctor Phil talk about this.
You want to blame the guy.
So she saying,
Lou reason that she saw his
cock was because you weren't
paying enough attention
to her. You need to try to
pay attention more to her.
Well,
she sucking his dick.
What do I do to stop this?
I don't know.
MMM.
At this point I would be
thinking about my kids
and how I could
make this as
look through.
This is what the fuck she wants to do.
Are you make this as easy a fucker?
Transition your fucking divorce. Uh,
I can tell you this.
I know you called her a whore here.
Don't ever say that to your kids
because at the end of the day,
it's still their mother and
you got to fucking, you know,
you got to look the other way.
Um, I dunno dude, this is,
this is outside my fucking realm.
Um,
I can tell you this dude,
you fucking 38 years old.
You sound like a great fucking guy.
Um,
I would just, whatever you got to
do for your kids, I would do that.
Her is a fucking lost cause.
All right.
And I would, um, yeah,
I would do that and I
would start P90x and,
and go out and get yourself a fucking
beautiful, goodhearted fucking woman.
I mean,
I would maybe even if you have time,
I would go to therapy and figure
out how the fuck you ended up.
Okay,
well she's just a total psycho.
Like,
so you don't go out and fucking marry
that again. Um, figure that out.
But the fuck I'm trying to marry
you off already. Jesus Christ.
You just getting out of something.
I don't know.
Do this by head spinning over this one
because I'm putting myself in your shoes.
I don't know what the fuck I would do.
Um,
oh man, that's a rough one.
Some other fucking guy going in
telling your kids to pipe down.
I mean, Jesus fucking Christ. Uh,
yeah, I would, I would, uh,
I would talk to somebody about this way
beyond my fucking educational level.
That's what I would do. I hope you
get through this thing and, uh,
what a fucking mistake she's making.
I can tell you that,
but she does the way you described it.
Granted, I gonna get your side of it.
She does not sound like the final person
that even when she does fuck it up,
she'll admit it.
She probably still put it on you and uh,
but you know what?
It'll all come out in the wash and you
kids are going to know that you're a
fucking good guy, so. Well, Jeez.
Can we, can we, can we end on that?
I don't know.
Okay.
I don't think so. Hang on a second, Nia.
Okay. My fault. I thought
she could come on. Uh,
she can't just get to do mommy duty.
I got to have it back on more, man.
Miss Savin around here. Um,
anyways, that's the, uh,
that's the podcast for this week.
Uh, how about those dolphins?
One and over top of the AFC east,
you know,
patriots won and one in second
place. Um, it's still early.
Kansas City looking fucking
tough. Uh, what else?
Cowboys' defense is in shambles.
Bread Ahrens to call me or text me
all fucking concerned about that.
But it's still early. It's still fucking
early. We'll see what's going on.
My beautiful daughter is
crying downstairs, so I'm
going to go handle that shit.
And literally and figuratively,
God knows
that's it.
About checkin on you on Thursday.
A joy the Monday night football
game tonight. And uh, once again,
congratulations to the Cleveland Indians,
22 in a row.
I've obviously never saw that ever. That's
in fucking incredible. That's almost,
I told someone is wanting a
month's worth of games. Yeah.
Built this 30 days in a month
and they almost play everyday.
Yeah. Thank you, Bill.
All right, go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you on Thursday.